bienvenue je vais remplacer
temporairement la présidente jusqu'à ce
qu'elle arrive si elle arrive
mais donc bienvenue merci d'être venu
nous procédons à la dernière de nos
auditions de la journée en attendant on
entend dans trois représentants de la
direction de la sécurité sociale madame
Clélia Delpech sous directrice du
financement du système de soins madame
Charlotte Mazia chef du bureau des
produits de santé et Madame Delphine
Champetier chef de service auprès du
directeur que je remercie de cette
mobilisée pour nous répondre en matière
de pénurie de médicaments il nous a
semblé incontournable de vous entendre
sur des sujets de l'accès aux soins des
Françaises et des Français et la
régulation par le prix des médicaments
car ils sont directement liés aux
équilibre financiers de la sécurité
sociale
votre administration est double mission
garantir l'accès aux soins de tous les
Français mais aussi limités au maximum
le coût pour la sécurité sociale de cet
accès au cours de nos travaux nous nous
sommes souvent interrogés pour savoir si
l'équilibre entre ces deux finalités tel
qu'il a été trouvé jusqu'à aujourd'hui
était le bon vous nous donnerez
j'imagine votre point de vue sur la
question la DSS est notamment chargée de
la préparation de la loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale or les dernières
LFSS ont apporté des changements parfois
subtils parfois importants au système de
fixation des prix de remboursement des
médicaments via la prise en compte des
coûts de réels ou des enjeux de
souveraineté de l'approvisionnement
notamment une mission lancée par la
première ministre doit aussi formuler
des pistes d'évolution de la régulation
du médicament nous avons entendu la
semaine passée et j'imagine que vous
avez été associé à ces travaux vous
pourrez donc nous dire si ces évolutions
traduisent peut-être un changement dans
le regard porté sur le médicament alors
qu'il était jusqu' ici perçu
principalement comme un coup pour le
système de santé devant être régulier
par London il est aujourd'hui redevenu
un pilier de notre souveraineté
sanitaire dont l'approvisionnement doit
être garantie presque à tout prix
vous pourrez aussi enfin nous éclairer
sur les enjeux respectifs des
médicaments matures et des médicaments
innovants au regard de leur poids dans
la dépense de santé constatez-vous de
fait un glissement de la dépense vers
les médicaments innovants et cela
traduit-il une nouvelle stratégie
commerciale des laboratoires
pharmaceutiques je rappelle que le
médicament qui coûte le plus cher à
notre système de santé représente une
dépense annuelle de plus de 1,5
milliards d'euros je vais maintenant
vous céder la parole pour un
pas du tout ah oui parce que
je vais maintenant vous c'est la parole
pour un bref propos introductif puis
Laurence Cohen notre rapporteur de la
commission d'enquête vous posera une
première série de questions je précise
que cette audition est diffusée en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat et
qu'elle fera l'objet d'un compte-rendu
publié avant de vous donner la parole je
vous rappelle qu'un faux témoignage
selon notre commission d'enquête est
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal je
vous invite à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure
vous avez la parole
merci madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs si vous le permettez comme
vous m'y avez invité je commencerai par
quelques mots de présentation rapide des
missions de la direction de sécurité
sociale en lien avec la politique du
médicament mais voilà vous avez rappelé
l'essentiel d'entraide dans dans votre
introduction et je continuerai mon
intervention limitée le rôle du prix
effectivement une autre vision de
l'impact du prix sur les questions de
pénurie qui
occupent votre commission d'enquête
avant de répondre à vos questions quel
est le rôle de la Direction de la
Sécurité sociale sur la politique du
médicament en fait je dirais qu'il y a
essentiellement trois rôles le premier
c'est que on est avec d'autres
directions et d'autres acteurs et voilà
c'est une politique très
interministérielle où chacun son filtre
et sa grille d'analyse et où chacun
aussi a un bout du puzzle sur
l'ensemble de la politique et donc on
participe avec d'autres directions et
d'autres acteurs à la négociation des
prix des produits de santé au sein du
comité économique des produits de santé
et nous notre filtre exactement comme
vous l'avez dit il est double
c'est-à-dire qu'on regarde le sujet du
prix en se disant dans quelle mesure ça
permet de garantir un accès à
l'innovation
et un accès au traitement pour les
patients et dans quelle mesure on est en
capacité de le faire dans un cadre qui
est soutenable puisque c'est un peu
notre ADN à la Direction de la Sécurité
sociale dans quelle mesure on le peut le
faire sans remettre en cause la
pérennité du financement de la sécurité
sociale c'est vraiment cette double
grille qu'on a systématiquement ça c'est
notre première mission notre seconde
mission c'est qu'on a quand même une
activité avec les autres directions du
ministère certaines d'entre elles que
vous avez auditionnées de conception et
de proposition de différents dispositifs
qui visent à faciliter l'accès au marché
pour pour des médicaments et notamment
pour des médicaments innovants voilà je
vais pas tous les citer ici mais c'est
vrai que dans le cadre des précédents
période SS on a travaillé sur l'accès
aux médicaments et thérapies innovantes
sur des systèmes d'accès direct
d'accès précoce d'accès compassionnel la
liste pourrait être longue mais en tout
cas chaque
année mais régulièrement nous avons une
cette activité un peu de réflexion sur
l'amélioration des conditions d'accès au
marché et puis notre troisième rôle
c'est celui effectivement de la
l'élaboration alors on n'est pas
évidemment pas le seul à le faire mais
en tout cas on travaille sur les
objectifs de progression de la dépense
d'Assurance Maladie pas seulement dans
le champ des produits de santé aussi sur
le des dépenses hospitalières les
dépenses
de ville
et dans ce cadre là on est à la fois
chargé de préparer
la trajectoire de la dépense sur lequel
on pourra évidemment revenir dans les
dans le cours de cette de cette audition
et aussi chargé de réfléchir à ce que
sont les voix et moyen pour tenir cette
trajectoire et donc sur parce que les
ressources publiques sont contraintes et
pas infinie que l'argent public reste
une ressource rare et qu'on veut
l'affecter là où il a le plus plus
d'impact ça suppose évidemment de
réfléchir à des médicaments de
régulation et donc il y a que en fait il
y a que deux manières de faire de la de
la régulation soit on agit sur les
tarifs soit on agit sur les volumes
il y a une alternative qui est de se
dire que c'est plus de l'argent public
qui est dépensé et c'est du transfert de
dépense vers d'autres financeurs du
système de soins que ce soit les
patients ou les organismes
complémentaires mais si on reste dans le
champ vraiment de la dépense de santé
dans le cadre de la dame voilà
l'alternative c'est celle là c'est
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on est en
capacité d'agir sur les volumes juste
redire très rapidement mais on pourra
revenir ensuite que en France mais vous
le voilà pardon pour les évidences mais
on est quand même un pays qui a un gros
consommateur de médicaments que il y a
quand même une partie des pénuries
auxquelles nous sommes confrontés
aujourd'hui qui pourrait être moins
sévère s'il y avait une consommation
plus raisonnable de certaines de
certaines molécules donc ça on le sait
donc cette action sur les volumes elle
est particulièrement importante elle
doit s'exercer à la fois envers les
professionnels de santé qui prescrivent
qui délivrent ces molécules et envers
les
patients les assurés qui consomment ces
molécules le deuxième levier c'est
l'action sur les prix donc j'y
reviendrai un petit peu plus tard si
vous le si vous le souhaitez juste quand
même établir une petite distinction sur
la régulation prix qui permet d'ouvrir
peut-être d'autres réflexions ensuite
qui est que la régulation sur les prix
elle se fondent sur
sur un double équilibre il y a ce qu'on
appelle nous une régulation micro
c'est-à-dire en fait les objectifs de
baisse de prix qu'on se fixe chaque
année dans les projets de loi de
financement et puis il y a cet outil sur
lequel on pourra revenir qui qu'on a un
outil au niveau on appelle ça de
régulation macro à posteriori qui
s'appelle la clause de sauvegarde et qui
vient garantir un niveau de progression
de la dépense et en fait garantir qu'on
dépasse pas le niveau qu'on avait qu'on
avait prévu et donc cette régulation sur
les prix elle marche vraiment sur ces
sur ces deux jambes et en fait
l'équilibre mais on y reviendra sans
doute ensuite entre ces deux jambes et
désormais un peu un peu évolué au cours
des dernières années ce qui a amené
voilà toutes les réflexions sur
l'évolution des de la fixation du prix
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire sur le
rôle du prix dans les dans les pénuries
voilà je redirai des choses je pense que
vous avez déjà attendu par différents
je pense que le prix c'est évidemment
pas du tout l'alpha et l'oméga de la
résolution de la question des pénuries
c'est un des éléments parmi d'autres
dans l'équation assez compliquées de ce
problème ce qu'on voit c'est que dans
des pays qui ont parfois des prix bien
plus élevés que les nôtres notamment sur
des médicaments matures
l'exemple de la de la Suisse il y a
quand même mais sans doute peut-être
parce que les volumes sont pas
suffisamment importants des difficultés
d'accès à certaines molécules et
d'autres pays où il y a à la fois les
volumes et les prix comme les États-Unis
ont aussi des difficultés d'accès à
certains médicaments ce qui veut donc
dire que voilà c'est un problème qui est
plus
général que celui des prix par contre ce
qui est important et ce qui est vraiment
une priorité que le gouvernement a fixé
au négociateur du comité économique des
produits de santé c'est que la politique
de prix ne vienne pas aggraver la
situation des des pénuries
donc on pourra revenir plus longuement
si vous le souhaitez sur les évolutions
du de la politique de prix sur peut-être
aussi une distinction qui me semble
assez importante sur
les prix des médicaments innovants par
rapport au prix des médicaments matures
voilà vous avez fait une ouverture sur
ce sujet et on voit bien que c'est
effectivement un des enjeux sur lesquels
on doit encore travailler dans les dans
les prochaines années pour faire quelque
chose de plus juste et sans doute de
plus protecteur pour les produits
matures qu'actuellement
et puis peut-être dire
au sein de mon introduction et sans
vouloir être trop longue à ce stade que
voilà il y a dans le cadre de la
politique de prix il y a un certain
nombre de leviers assez récents qui ont
été mises en place pour justement
essayer d'adresser avec plein d'autres
outils et plein d'autres réflexions que
le gouvernement a initié essayer de
lutter contre les pénuries de
médicaments et donc à ce stade je ne
fais que les citer mais on pourra y
revenir un petit peu plus longuement si
vous le souhaitez vous savez qu'il y a
eu récemment un moratoire
sur les diminutions de diminution de
prix pour les médicaments génériques qui
a été décidé avec justement l'idée de
protéger ses produits matures de baisse
de prix supplémentaires
dans le cadre de l'accord cadre qui est
un des éléments de des règles qu'on
applique pour fixer les prix il y a un
article l'article 28 qui permet de
solliciter dans certaines conditions des
augmentations de prix et on a aussi un
article 65 d'une précédente loi de
financement celle de 2022 qui vise à
mieux prendre en compte la question de
la sécurité d'approvisionnement lié à
l'implantation sur le territoire
français bon sur ce dernier article
comme vous le savez avec les échanges
que vous avez eu on a finalisé
l'élaboration de la de la doctrine ce
qui a pris un peu de temps et donc voilà
maintenant il va il va pleinement
rentrer en vigueur voilà pour
l'essentiel de ce que je voulais dire à
ce stade en introduction madame apprécie
merci beaucoup est-ce que le propos
liminaire et je peux le considérer comme
fini d'accord très bien et je vous
remercie et je donne donc immédiatement
la parole à notre rapporteur Laurence
Cohen pour une première série de
questions
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
pour votre propos introductif
moi j'aimerais vous poser des questions
concernant notamment
l'ONDAM et sur le fait que nous n'avons
pas nous en tout cas de visibilité au
niveau de la dépense de médicaments
concernant spécialement l'hôpital et on
a une enveloppe une enveloppe fermée
qui joue un peu enfin avec les vases
communicants c'est-à-dire que c'est
aussi bien pour les médicaments mature
que les médicaments innovants donc on
sent qu'il y a une baisse importante des
des produits matures qui permet de
pouvoir répondre à l'envoler assez
pharaonique des des produits dit
innovants mais on n'a pas de visibilité
au niveau de l'enveloppe entre la
différence entre donc l'hôpital et pour
le dire vite la médecine de ville est-ce
que vous vous pouvez nous donner des
éléments sur cette question ça c'est ma
première interrogation la deuxième
interrogation c'est concernant il y a eu
un rapport du Sénat qui s'appelle
pilotage de la dépense de santé vous le
connaissez certainement redonner du sens
à la dame et qui propose en fait de
retracer de manière consolidée les
dépenses de produits de santé dans
l'ONDAM qu'est-ce que vous pensez en
fait de cette de cette proposition et
finalement est-ce que vous vous pensez
que ça serait une bonne chose de faire
une qu'il y ait une distinction au sein
de l'ONDAM entre par exemple la dépense
des génériques et celles des princesses
est-ce que ça ça pourrait être de nature
à aider ma troisième question c'est
concernant la la mission borne dites
borne nous avons donc nous les avons
auditionné est-ce que vous au niveau
donc de la Direction de la Sécurité
sociale vous êtes vous avez été
auditionné donc par cette par cette
commission et est-ce que vous êtes
associé d'une façon ou d'une autre à
cette régulation du médicament
ma troisième question c'est plutôt ma
quatrième
comment est-ce que vous défendez
toujours au niveau des prix comment
est-ce que vous défendez
votre position au sein du CEPS
et quels éléments précis de chiffrage
d'évaluation apportez-vous à la table de
négociation devant les industriels
il était à ce propos et ça fait partie
de la question c'est qu'il était il
était prévu que les hausses de prix se
fasse notamment en contrepartie
d'engagement précis de la part des
industriels sur une sécurité du marché
français et est-ce que finalement vous
pouvez nous donner des précisions sur
ces engagements et aussi une assurance
du fait que les industriels respectent
ces engagements parce que là on voit
bien y compris dans les annonces qu'a
fait le président de la République alors
c'est pas sur le même Regis c'est sur la
relocalisation il y a des fonds qui sont
donnés aux industriels on a le sentiment
un peu qui a pas vraiment de
conditionnalités très ferme qui leur
sont
qui leur sont donnés la
cinquième question c'est sur le critère
industriel le chrétien industriel qui a
été donc qui est prévu au niveau du
PLFSS 2022 et est-ce qu'il faut comme le
souhaite les industriels permettent
l'application du critère industriel de
l'article donc le 65 de la LSS pour 2022
aux produits matures qui sont d'ores et
déjà inscrit au remboursement
et
une deuxième question sur le même Regis
est-ce que vous pensez que ce nouveau
critère permettra de mieux valoriser les
produits matures qui sont fabriqués sur
le sol français ou d'ailleurs sur le sol
européen et donc encourager la pérennité
des pardon des relocalisations
et puis j'ai deux ou trois questions sur
la clause de sauvegarde sur la clause de
sauvegarde donc elle est à peu près
évaluée à un milliard d'euros
bon c'est une c'est une évaluation au
moment où on se parle où on échange mais
je pense pas qu'il y ait une marge de
d'erreur trop importante vous me le
direz mais est-ce que vous êtes en
mesure d'estimer la part de clause de
sauvegarde générée générée par le
chiffre d'affaires sur les médicaments
essentiels qui sont définis dans la
liste qui vient d'être publiée par le
ministère de la Santé de la prévention
on attendait beaucoup de de cette liste
il y a une liste de 450 médicaments avec
50 médicaments di critiques est-ce que
vous avez une évaluation en tout cas par
rapport à la aux 450 médicaments et
enfin la dernière question c'est
toujours sur la clause de sauvegarde
est-ce que pour vous il serait pertinent
de en fait de
mettre un critère au niveau de la clause
de sauvegarde qui prennent compte en
fait la
criticité industrielle mais surtout
thérapeutique du médicament concerné
puisque ça c'est un élément qui ne
rentre pas en compte dans la clause de
sauvegarde alors qu'on sait que les
négociations du CEPS avec les
industriels et value un peu tous les
éléments qui peuvent entrer en ligne de
compte dans le médicament y compris la
porte thérapeutique etc dans la clause
de sauvegarde ça n'est pas le cas donc
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est un
élément pertinent ou pas si nous vous
interrogeons un petit peu de manière
peut-être un peu poussée sur la clause
de sauvegarde c'est qu'effectivement il
y a eu beaucoup de critiques lors des
auditions sur cette clause de sauvegarde
par le fait que finalement il ne peut
pas y avoir d'anticipation au niveau des
industriels mais ce qu'on a ressenti
c'est que comme cette clause de
sauvegarde finalement s'exerce quel que
soit l'entreprise il y a pas de
différence entre je vais mettre dans le
paquet big en main et les PM donc ça
peut poser un problème là aussi
peut-être qu'il faudrait différencier je
vous remercie par avance
merci Madame la rapporteur pour
l'ensemble de vos questions
je vais répondre avec l'aide de
Charlotte sur quelques points donc sur
le premier sur la question de la
visibilité de la dépense de médicaments
sur le champ ville plus hôpital dans la
dame et puis la question qui est un
petit peu liée qui est la réflexion
effectivement que nous on a eu et puis
d'autres avec nous autour de l'idée que
peut-être on pourrait essayer de
constituer un sous-objectif
pour parler enfin voilà comme il y a un
objectif sur les soins de vie un
objectif sur l'hôpital avoir un objectif
en fait sur les produits de santé aussi
au sein de au sein de la dame alors
oui la dépense de médicaments en fait
elle se retrouve à plusieurs endroits
dans les dépenses d'assurance maladie on
a une vision assez fine sur les dépenses
qui sont réalisées du côté de la ville
parce qu'on a les moyens de le suivre en
plus dans les systèmes d'information de
l'assurance maladie et donc là on a des
analyses très très fine et très poussées
du côté de l'hôpital les dépenses de
médicaments en fait elles se retrouvent
à deux endroits dans les circuits de
financement et se retrouvent d'une part
dans une liste qu'on appelle la
distension qui est réservée en fait au
molécules et aux dispositifs médicaux
qui sont les plus innovants onéreux
enfin pour lesquels on veut que ça ne
pèse pas en fait sur le budget des
établissements et ils se retrouvent la
dépense de médicaments du côté des
établissements de santé se retrouvent
également de là de cette liste qu'on
appelle la liste en Suisse dans
le financement de l'activité des
établissements et donc en fait c'est
payé dans le cadre du financement qu'on
accorde aux établissements sur leur
activité et en fait avec cette argent-là
les établissements passent ensuite des
marchés et acquièrent en fait c'est
médicaments et ses produits de santé
avec voilà un système que vous
connaissez de centrales de centrales
d'achat etc et donc c'est vrai que là
pour le coup enfin sous ton contrôle
Charlotte mais c'est vrai qu'on perd un
peu la vision très fine alors on a on
peut la voir on peut retrouver les
éléments d'information je pense en
difficulté en passant par des
connaissances que peuvent avoir des
centrales comme une achat enfin ou de ou
d'autres voilà mais par contre c'est
vrai qu'en termes on va dire comptable
et consolidée dans l'âme on n'a pas
forcément cette vision totale de la
dépense des produits de santé donc juste
vous dire que effectivement on a
réfléchi et on a d'ailleurs échangé avec
les industriels notamment sur la
question à la suite du rapport de pour
l'avenir de l'assurance maladie
qui a été fait par le HK me récemment on
avait un peu essayé de tirer le fil de
la mise en place d'un objectif sur les
produits de santé
bon ça
les réflexions n'ont pas c'est pas
encore complètement abouti ça présente
effectivement l'avantage de pouvoir
identifier clairement la dépense de
santé et peut-être aussi avoir un niveau
de compréhension sur ce qu'est la
progression de cette dépense spécifique
parce que c'est un sujet qu'on a
beaucoup c'est ça demande un petit peu
de retraitements à chaque fois et donc
il y a parfois aussi des difficultés de
compréhension entre les entre les
acteurs que ça présenterait cet avantage
là a priori après voilà ça ça a aussi
ça enlèverait l'avantage qui est que à
ce stade les dépenses qui sont des
dépenses hospitalières au titre de la
liste en Suisse elle serait mise dans un
autre ensemble qui est pas forcément non
plus très cohérent donc bon sur cette
norme là les réflexions sont en cours
mais on n'est pas
pas complètement les uns et les autres
très déterminés sur enfin après
convaincus sur le fait qu'il faille y
aller ou pas pour pour l'instant
sur la question sur la mission avec les
personnalités qualifiées
qui réfléchit à l'évolution de la
régulation du médicament la mission aux
born que vous avez cité oui on est en
contact très régulier avec eux on les
voit d'ailleurs par exemple demain
après-midi demain matin on les a
beaucoup
pas mal d'échanges pendant le leur
mission avec plein d'autres acteurs
parce qu'ils ont rencontré beaucoup de
beaucoup de monde
voilà peut-être juste sur le contexte de
cette mission
et ça rejoint aussi les questions que
vous posiez à la fin sur la clause de
sauvegarde c'est vrai que cette mission
elle arrive aussi à un moment où on se
repose un peu collectivement la question
de la bonne régulation sur
l'enveloppe médicament des projets de
loi de financement et donc la question
qui vous proposer à la mission c'est
voilà là on voit qu'on est sur un une
situation où on a une cause de
sauvegarde qui effectivement extrêmement
élevé sur 2022 on est à plus d'un
milliard à ce stade comme vous l'avez
comme vous l'avez indiqué
et donc il faut sans doute qu'on
réfléchisse à des moyens de régulation
qui soient à la fois plus
prévisible plus efficace peut-être pour
les les industriels et voilà qui soit
moins
irritant que c'est qui est devenu la
clause la clausée sauvegarde donc ça
nous on attend beaucoup des conclusions
de la de la mission l'objectif c'est
qu'elle puisse
se qu'elle puisse
nous faire des propositions qui puissent
ensuite être
expertisé et analysé pour se métaboliser
dans le prochain projet de de
financement de la sécurité sociale c'est
le calendrier qui a été et l'objectif
qui a été fixé à la mission après nous
le point d'attention qu'on a partagé
avec la mission et qu'on partage avec
vous c'est que encore une fois dans un
univers de ressources publiques
contrainte
il faudra de toute façon que la mission
soit en capacité de proposer des des
pistes qui soient pas
complètement en anomalie par rapport à
ce qu'est actuellement le taux de
progression de la dépense de produits de
santé tout simplement parce que on
n'aura pas les moyens de
d'aller très très au-delà donc
voilà il y a cette mission qui est qui
est en cours et avec laquelle on a des
échanges réguliers dont on attend
effectivement
les conclusions avec avec beaucoup
d'intérêts et d'impatience
pardonnez-moi mais en fait mes questions
peut-être n'étaient pas suffisamment
précise mais donc
ma question n'était pas tant est-ce que
vous êtes associés même si effectivement
je voulais poser donc vous avez répondu
mais en fait c'est vous qu'est-ce que
vous faites comme proposition y compris
à cette mission borne de manière un peu
précise et qu'elles sont les
propositions que vous considérez comme
disruptive et qui voilà que vous portez
que vous défendez parce que seulement
savoir que que j'allais dire on s'en
doutait c'était un peu Inuit mais après
qu'est-ce que vous vous portez qu'est-ce
que vous défendez parce que la clause de
sauvegarde elle a quand même un intérêt
c'est qu'elle permet de faire rentrer de
l'argent dans les caisses publiques et
aussi de prendre en considération le
chiffre d'affaires d'entreprise qui pour
certaines ont de très gros bénéfices
mais pas pour toutes donc finalement
vous vous avez une position en tant que
direction
merci
on a évidemment des réflexions et des
pistes de
voilà d'évolution de la de la clause de
sauvegarde après vraiment le sens de la
mission c'est aussi que elle puisse elle
voilà proposer des évolutions et des
adaptations de la régulation telle
qu'elle fonctionne actuellement donc
nous comme vous l'avez dit ce qui est
important pour nous c'est que la clause
de sauvegarde son objectif initial quand
elle a été créée il y a 15 ans c'était
pas dans l'esprit c'était pas du tout
d'avoir un rendement du niveau qu'elle a
atteint actuellement tel qu'on quand on
a créé la cause de sauvegarde l'idée
c'était d'avoir une mesure qui viennent
quelque part sécurisée un taux de
progression de la dépense de médicaments
mais qui
se venait après des négociations
tarifaires et les objectifs de baisse de
prix qui sont fixés chaque année auprès
du comité économique des des produits de
santé et en fait ce dont on s'aperçoit à
la faveur des dernières années c'est que
ces objectifs
ils sont pour partir un peu plus
difficiles à tenir et pour partie aussi
le niveau d'ambition de la régulation
micro c'est-à-dire à l'entrée des
produits de santé sur sur le marché puis
au fur et à mesure de la vie des
produits
il a aussi un peu un peu diminué et donc
dans un environnement de progression
contrainte de la dépense quand on fait
ça la conclusion logique j'ai envie de
dire mathématiques c'est que le système
de régulation a postériori qu'est la
clause de sauvegarde va continuer de
grossir jusqu'à atteindre des montants
qui sont en effet important actuellement
et effectivement qu'on est en capacité
de calculer la postérior donc avec des
voilà une visibilité qui est réduite
pour les les industriels donc nous on a
déjà d'ailleurs on propose je pense à
peu près chaque année des évolutions
plus ou moins importantes sur sur la
cause de sauvegarde par exemple dans le
PEL FS de cette année il y a une
distinction qui a été établie entre
l'assiette sur le chiffre d'affaires et
la situation du chiffre d'affaires avec
voilà une règle de répartition entre les
deux on voit bien que dans le cadre des
réflexions autour des produits matures
et ça répond par non aux questions de la
fin que vous aviez il y a peut-être des
choses en fait supplémentaires à
envisager pour regarder comment
la clause de sauvegarde peut peser
éventuellement moins sur ces produits
d'une manière ou d'une autre donc voilà
nous on est dans une phase aussi un
petit peu de réflexion évidemment sur
ces sujets on est aussi dans une phase
un petit peu de d'attente aussi de
proposition de du rapport de ces de ces
personnalités qualifiées et de toute
façon l'objectif pour nous c'est bien
que ce travail soit fait dans les
semaines et moi qui viennent pour
trouver une traduction parce qu'on
espère dans le cadre du prochain projet
de loi de financement
voilà donc à ce stade je peux pas être
beaucoup plus précise que ça dans mes
dans mes réponses
pour pour ces raisons sur la manière
dont on négocie au CEPS je peux
peut-être laisser Charlotte qui ne
négociatrice vous expliquez oui alors
juste avant de vous parler du CEPS une
précision sur le premier point on pourra
tout à fait vous pardon oui on pourra
tout à fait vous transmettre des les
données qu'on a donc les chiffres sur la
dépense de médicaments en ville en
rétrocession et sur la liste en Suisse
donc les seuls données qu'on a pas de
manière fine c'est ce que disait madame
Champetier les données des médicaments
financées via les tarifs hospitaliers
mais on peut tout à fait vous donner un
historique sur les dernières années et
on CRAPA de le faire alors s'agissant de
l'implication de la DSS au sein du
comité économique des produits de santé
notre rôle comme le rôle des autres
membres c'est de proposer des
propositions tarifaires qui respectent
les règles de tarification qu'on connaît
donc des règles légales inscrit dans le
code de la sécurité sociale des règles
réglementaires dans le même code et puis
des règles de politiques
conventionnelles définies par les
différents accords cadres et respecter
également les orientations données par
les ministres dans les lettres
d'orientation ministérielle donc à
chaque dossier analysé on regarde les
données économiques présentées par
l'industriel l'état du marché existant
donc le coût des alternatives leur
volume
les prévisions aussi de volume de du
médicament négocié puisque on tient
évidemment compte de l'impact budgétaire
puisque tout ça s'inscrit dans le cadre
de l'ONDAM donc on doit aussi faire
attention à la régulation à l'entrée
donc quel niveau de prix on accorde aux
nouveaux médicaments
pour ne pas
[Musique]
enfin les règles égales sont claires la
politique conventionnelle du dernier
accord cadre conduit à accorder beaucoup
de
de bénéfices et c'est normal puisque
c'est l'objet d'une politique
conventionnelle mais peut-être interroge
sur l'équilibre auquel vous faisiez
référence en introduction sur les la
régulation sur les produits matures et
les produits innovants et notamment sur
leur niveau de prix puisque c'est
bénéfices conventionnels peuvent
interroger au regard des niveaux de prix
public octroyés si on s'intéresse aux
prix revendiqué par exemple du coup de
traitement maximal en 2018 il était de
600 000 euros en cette année il dépasse
3 millions d'euros donc on peut
s'interroger sur le fait que cette
politique conventionnelle parfois permet
d’accorder des bénéfices de prix public
à hauteur du prix revendiqué par
l'industriel donc
voilà c'est ça nous ça nous interroge et
on en tient compte dans les dans les
négociations de prix pour essayer de
limiter au maximum ces déséquilibres
vous posiez également la question des
contreparties sollicitées lorsqu'on a
recours à l'article 28 de l'accord cadre
donc il existe des contreparties
l'article de l'accord-cadre le dilu
lui-même alors j'ai plus la phrase
exacte mais donc on y est écrit que le
bénéfice des dispositions étant entendu
la hausse de prix accordée le cas
échéant prévu au présent articles
s'accompagne d'un engagement de
l'entreprise à approvisionner le marché
français et à défaut s'il est démontré
que la responsabilité de l'entreprise
est en cause dans la rupture
d'approvisionnement le comité peut
aligner le prix public au prix net ce
qui est une sanction financière assez
dissuasive pour pour l'industriel
donc une contrepartie est quand même
attendue et heureusement sur
l'approvisionnement du marché on
pourrait s'interroger également sur
l'opportunité de davantage durcir cette
engagement
sur son application
l'article 28 est de plus en plus
sollicité par les industriels
quand on avait l'habitude de recevoir à
peu près 5
demandes par trimestre on voit que sur
le dernier trimestre 2023 on en a reçu
quasiment 30 donc la demande augmente on
fait évidemment très attention en ceps
accorder ses bénéfices lorsqu'il les
pertinent donc lorsque les des hausses
de coup sont observées qui pourraient
mettre en péril le maintien sur le
marché d'un médicament dont le besoin
thérapeutique est important et qui ne
serait plus couvert si le médicament
venait à disparaître du marché
néanmoins on constate un effet d'aubaine
majeur sur ces derniers mois
des sur des demandes de hausse de prix
qui ne correspondent pas à l'esprit de
cet article
et qui sont d'ailleurs dégoûtés par le
comité économique des produits de santé
en revanche sur le taux d'éligibilité
sur le nombre de dossiers le nombre de
spécialités qui ont demandé à bénéficier
de cet article 28 pour 40% d'entre eux
ils ont ils ont enfin une éligibilité
une hausse de prix accordée au regard
évidemment des documents qu'ils arrivent
à nous fournir et à justifier leur
demande
voilà pour ce qui était de l'implication
des SS et peut-être juste pour répondre
à vos dernières questions sur la
sur dans quelle mesure la clause de
sauvegarde s'applique à la liste de
médicaments essentiels qui a été annoncé
en fait on n'a pas encore regardé mais
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on peut faire
et qu'on peut vous communiquer ensuite
oui tout à fait peut-être
en
pour vous donner une première
information lorsque
en fait c'est assez difficile d'estimer
la part de la contribution liée à une
molécule en particulier puisque la
clause de sauvegarde s'entend par
laboratoire par chiffre d'affaires de
laboratoire donc ce qu'on a essayé de de
regarder c'est de qualifier un
laboratoire de généricur en fonction de
la part de médicaments génériques
composant son chiffre d'affaires et pour
vous donner une idée sur cette analyse
là la contribution de la clause de
sauvegarde aujourd'hui se répartit à 80%
sur des laboratoires non génériques
encore une fois la qualification relève
d'un proxy que l'on a que l'on a fait il
y a 20% sur des laboratoires exploitants
des génériques une grosse part de
générique
merci beaucoup pour pour ces réponses
de trois petites questions et puis après
si madame n'a rapporté vous avez
d'autres questions non simplement pour
revenir sur ce que vous avez dit sur le
l'effet d'aubaine que vous constatez
est-ce que
vous donc vous dites 40 dans 40% des cas
c'est justifié et donc l'augmentation
est accordée
j'en ai vu que dans 60% des cas ça l'est
pas
est-ce que vous observez un effet sur la
disponibilité des médicaments sur les
60%
qui sont refusées et les deux autres
questions n'ont rien à voir la première
c'est sur les l'aspect européen de
la négociation avec l'industrie
l'affixation des prix est-ce que vous
partagez l'idée que
une meilleure coordination du système de
sécurité sociale au niveau européen et
une des clés pour avoir une meilleure
maîtrise des prix puisque si la
négociation se fait face à des acteurs
coordonnés et bien elle est à l'avantage
des acteurs qui se coordonnent donc si
on avait une meilleure coordination dans
les négociations on n'arriverait
peut-être à négocier de meilleures prix
et la dernière question qui est sur un
sujet tout à fait différent mais qui est
lié à la un des aspects de du prix des
médicaments c'est sur la question des
droits de propriété intellectuelles sur
les brevets
on a quand même un phénomène où
il y a des il y a des brevets qui sont
accordés sur
des médicaments dont parfois
grande partie de la recherche
fondamentale sur laquelle est basée
l'innovation du médicament a été
financée par la recherche publique
est-ce que parmi les propositions
subversives
potentiel pour pour améliorer la
question du prix des médicaments il y a
des réflexions sur la la structure des
brevets accordés par exemple le fait que
si on constate que
la moitié
de
des investissements qui ont été
nécessaires à la création d'un
médicament ça a déjà été financé par le
public parce que c'était de la recherche
publique voilà est-ce qu'il y a des
réflexions sur le refléter cette
structure de financement dans le brevet
final par exemple que voilà si on
considère que une entreprise a contribué
seulement pour moitié à la création du
médicament parce que l'autre moitié
c'était du financement public le brevet
soit accordé sur la moitié enfin bref
que le droit de propriétaire sexuel soit
plus faible et qui reflète en fait les
investissements merci
votre première question portait sur les
60% de dossiers sur lesquels les
visibilité n'est pas accordée à la
hausse de prix alors il y a encore un
peu tôt pour vous dire si on a constaté
un effet sur les ruptures aux tensions
on pourra en revanche mener l'analyse et
vous la transmettre par écrit le lien
n'est pas évident à faire là comme ça
sur
le fait d'avoir une politique
européenne de fixation des prix c'est
effectivement sans doute quelque chose
qui est à rechercher et à privilégier et
à construire parce qu'il y a tout un
cadre réglementaire qui n'est pas encore
complètement
stabilisés conçus suffisamment voilà
suffisamment très à l'emploi mais c'est
vrai qu'on voit que ça donne
en fait si on a une politique d'humid
médicament
au niveau européen on a déjà des volumes
qui sont potentiellement beaucoup plus
importants et donc un poids dans la
négociation qui est plus important et
d'autre part on peut aussi se prémunir
un peu de ce phénomène de concurrence
entre pays qu'on peut observer parfois
même au niveau européen donc
effectivement c'est des sujets sur
lequel nous direction la sécurité
sociale on n'est pas particulièrement
nous qui travaillons sur ces aspects là
mais tout à fait ça fait partie des
objectifs du du gouvernement et sur
votre dernière question qui est dans
quelle mesure on peut essayer de prendre
en compte dans la fixation du prix la
contribution publique à aux efforts de
recherche et développement de des
entreprises en fait c'est vrai qu'on a
un système en fait quand on fixe un prix
on s'inscrit dans un ensemble de règles
qui est très maintenant codée sédimentés
et en fait ce qu'on vraiment ce qu'on
regarde pour l'instant c'est la question
de l'amélioration du service médical
rendu et c'est un peu ça qui est la
boussole en fait pour fixer le juste
niveau de rémunération et donc je ne
crois pas qu'à ce stade on est la
capacité de se dire qu'on regarde la
vision d'ensemble de
l'entreprise et de son accompagnement
par des crédits publics aussi bien
d'ailleurs en amont qu'on avale parce
que on pourrait se dire qu'il y a aussi
d'autres moments dans la vie des
produits ou dans la vie de l'entreprise
où il y a différents systèmes
d'aide aux entreprises aux industries
qui existent et qui ne rétroagissent pas
sur le prix donc on a enfin comme vous
le savez il y a un certain nombre de
dispositions dans les précédents projets
de loi de financement qui vise à essayer
d'améliorer un peu cette vision qu'on
peut avoir de la réalité économique des
entreprises mais il y a sans doute
encore des
améliorations des progrès à faire sur
cette
oui mais merci pour pour ces précisions
en même temps vous savez qu'on est vous
êtes devant une commission d'enquête
donc on a besoin de réponses très
précises à nos questions qui le sont et
bon vous votez
au niveau des de la fixation des prix
aux côtés avec le CEPS donc vous avez
quand même
des vous portez un certain nombre de
propositions que vous essayez de faire
valoir et de faire entendre donc ce
serait bien que vous puissiez nous les
donner de manière plus plus précise et
pas seulement je crois pas tout à fait
que que vous avez seulement des
suggestions et que certainement que vous
attendez les résultats de la mission
board j'en doute pas tout le monde les
attend mais je pense que vous-même vous
avez quand même des propositions que
vous avez tenté de faire valoir donc ça
c'est quand même un peu plus précis
deuxième chose il me semble mais
peut-être que
je me trompe mais je ne crois pas que
vous n'avez pas vraiment répondu à deux
choses c'est-à-dire quand je vous ai
demandé le côté du critère industriel
est-ce que pour vous c'est un plus
est-ce que c'est c'est pas une bonne
idée est-ce que
parce que on a aussi entendu que ça
pouvait être aussi compliqué
parce que ça paraît être aussi une idée
de bon sens de bien évaluer le coût de
production
ceci dit le coût de production par
exemple
on nous a dit attention il peut y avoir
gonflement du coût de production par les
par les industriels donc il y a toujours
quand on fait une proposition il faut
avoir la capacité de contrôle pour pour
être le plus juste possible donc
qu'est-ce que vous pensez précisément de
ce critères et deuxième question à
laquelle me semble-t-il vous n'avez pas
tout à fait répondu non plus c'est
concernant les critères à savoir le
service rendu en termes de santé de
santé publique alors effectivement la
clause de sauvegarde n'était pas faite
pour ça enfin je veux dire au départ
mais est-ce que vous ne croyez pas
qu'avec l'évolution des choses etc il y
a pas justement puisque nombreux et
nombreux sont celles qui demandent une
évolution de cette clause de sauvegarde
est-ce que cette évolution pourrait
pendant cette évolution pour cette
évolution en faveur de cette évolution
il pourrait pas y avoir cette cette
clause particulière supplémentaire qui
pourrait donc aider voilà les trois
questions que je voulais vous poser je
vous remercie
sur donc sur la participation la
Direction de la Sécurité sociale au
comité économique des produits santé en
fait les
on peut voir quel type de précision vous
souhaitez qu'on apporte mais en fait
c'est des on a des discussions vraiment
sur un format très régulier plusieurs
fois par semaine sur un ensemble de
dossiers et donc effectivement on est
amené à défendre des positions mais
c'est peut-être un peu enfin difficile
ici de vous de vous lister par ailleurs
ça sera un peu compliqué de citer les
les produits donc voilà mais il faut
compléter la réponse on le on le fera
sans difficulté juste sur les questions
de proposition qu'on a pu faire je
voudrais quand même
si tu es une proposition qu'on avait
déjà faite sur un précédent projet de
loi de financement et dont certaines des
personnes que vous avez auditionné vous
ont parlé nous on avait en tête l'idée
de pouvoir quand on négocie avec un
industriel lié à une négociation sur un
produit qui arrive sur le marché
avec des contreparties sur une sécurité
d'approvisionnement sur des produits
matures de son portefeuille donc ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on avait proposé
dans le cadre du précédent projet de loi
de financement et voilà il y a la fin à
la faveur de divers échanges
concertation discussions ça n'a pas été
retenu voilà mais c'était une
proposition qu'on avait qu'on avait pu
faire et encore une fois il peut y en
avoir plein d'autres mais après on est
encore un stade de l'année où on a
évidemment pas de on a ni finaliser en
fait ce que sont nos propositions aussi
quand même je le redis dans l'attente
des propositions de la de la mission
born et d'autre part on a bien sûr pas
du tout de décision politique sur le
contenu de des propositions qu'on
pourrait faire donc c'est vraiment
difficile à ce stade d'aller plus loin
sur sur cette réponse
sur les les critères la question du
critère industriel
je serai Charlotte compléter mais c'est
enfin voilà l'idée elle est elle est on
la comprend parfaitement c'est le se
dire que effectivement il y a une forme
de sécurité d'approvisionnement qui est
lié au fait que l'entreprise se situe
sur sur le territoire et on comprend
aussi que
cette ce critère là et cette situation
là a de la de la valeur donc c'est voilà
sur le principe il y a pas de
on prend complètement cette décision qui
a été prise par par le gouvernement
après sur les modalités d'application et
la question des modes de la connaissance
de l'information qu'on peut avoir sur la
le niveau
de rémunération accorder à ce titre
voilà je pense qu'on a en fait on est
encore un stade où on va regarder sur
les dossiers qui vont nous arriver
comment notre doctrine va fonctionner
quoi
et sur
la question du service rendu parce que
ce que vous voulez dire juste pour être
sûr de bien comprendre c'est l'évolution
du mode de tarification c'est ça du
médicament c'est le fait de changer de
par rapport à l'amélioration du service
médical c'est toujours dans c'est
toujours dans la clause de sauvegarde
c'est à dire prendre en compte le
service thérapeutique rendu le service
médical en quelque sorte comme un
critère supplémentaire en fait oui
pardon excusez-moi alors ça fait
complètement partie des réflexions qu'on
pourrait avoir après c'est vrai que la
question de la cause de sauvegarde à un
moment il faut qu'on regarde alors nous
on y est quand même très attaché à la
direction de sécurité sociale pourquoi
parce que c'est un outil qui est qui est
très très efficace et qui nous permet
d'atteindre le voilà le but un de nos
objectifs qui est le respect de la de la
de la dépense sur les produits de santé
après les évolutions qu'on fait en fait
il faut trouver l'équilibre entre la
visibilité pour les acteurs économiques
quelque chose qui soit enfin voilà qui
est une complexité
modérée aussi pour que ça reste
compréhensible et donc voilà c'est un
peu sur ces différents leviers là qu'il
faudra qu'on joue dans les dans les dans
les prochaines mes prochains mois si on
doit faire bouger la clause de
sauvegarde
peut-être en complément sur ce dernier
point c'est si vous faites référence aux
médicaments à niveau de d'amélioration
du service médical rendu important 1 à 3
ces médicaments là finalement sont déjà
largement valorisés par le prix qu'on
leur qu'on leur accorde donc ce serait
enfin ça poserait un peu une question
quand à la prise en compte de nouveau
dans la répartition de la contribution
pour alléger leur participation alors
même qu'ils sont responsables du
dépassement en majorité de la clause
donc
prendre un critère supplémentaire
effectivement ça pourrait être
intéressant mais est-ce que c'est celui
là il faut qu'on regarde en impact
puisque là comme ça ça paraît pas si
évident
et pour revenir du coup sur votre
question du critère industriel
l'article 65 donc en fait répond au même
objectif que l'article 28 sécuriser
l'approvisionnement l'approvisionnement
lorsque il y a un investissement pour
pour relocaliser une partie de la
production en France ou en Europe
ce critère est intéressant en revanche
il faut qu'on fasse attention à ce que
le la relocalisation enfin le changement
amené par l'industriel vient vraiment
palier le la fragilité sur la chaîne
d'approvisionnement constaté si ce
changement n'apporte rien de plus sur la
sécurité d'approvisionnement alors il ne
serait pas justifié après la difficulté
qu'on a c'est de pouvoir vous l'avez dit
avoir les compétences pour
juger de la de des bons critères
industriels de la bonne relocalisation
et là au sein du comité économique des
produits de santé les compétences sont
plutôt à la main de la Direction
générale des entreprises qui connaît
mieux que nous ces sujets là donc
le critère est intéressant mais encore
faut-il avoir les moyens de pouvoir
s'assurer de leur opportunité pertinence
effectivement
juste par rapport par rapport à ça sur
le critère industriel donc là vous venez
de préciser les choses mais par exemple
quand les industries les industriels
depuis 30 ans ont délocalisé en fait on
le sait pour essayer de de pouvoir
bénéficier en fait de critères
environnementaux et sociaux moi
j'exigeants dans dans les pays notamment
en Asie Chine Indes etc et à partir du
moment où aujourd'hui il relocalise il
faut qu'il y ait une compte de ces de
ces critères environnementaux sociaux
est-ce que ça peut être englobé dans le
critère industriel ou pas du tout
c'est un petit peu moins dans notre
champ de compétence directe pour le coup
je pense que c'est
des sujets qui sont peut-être plus
suivis par la Direction générale des
entreprises mais
il me semble que ça fait partie des
choses qui sont envisagées par le
gouvernement effectivement d'avoir
d'intégrer certains critères type RSE
mais pour le coup pour nous c'est un
petit peu compliqué d'être on n'est pas
les plus compétents du tout sur sur cet
aspect là de la de la politique
merci
beaucoup avant que je lève la séance
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres éléments que
vous souhaiteriez porter à notre
connaissance très bien dans ce cas-là je
vous invite à lorsque vous nous
transmettez les réponses par écrit à
être peut-être un peu plus détaillé et
précis que ce que ça a pu être
aujourd'hui
puisque bon c'est une évidence c'est une
commission d'enquête donc nous avons
besoin des éléments les plus précis dont
vous disposez pour pouvoir finaliser nos
travaux comme il se doit si il n'y a pas
d'autres questions et bien je vous
remercie et la séance est levée